200 years of modern science we have to
admit that our performance is not great
the machines will build continue to
suffer from mechanical failures the
houses were built do not survive severe
earthquakes but we shouldn't be so
critical about our scientists for a
simple reason they didn't have much time
200 years is not a lot of time well
nature had 3 billion years to perfect
some of the most amazing materials that
we wish we had in our possession
remember these materials carry a quality
assurance of 3 billion years
take for example sequoia trees they
carry hundreds of tones for hundreds of
years in cold weather in warm climates
UV light yet if you look in the
structure by high-resolution electron
microscopy and you ask yourself what is
it made of surprisingly it's made of
sugar well not exactly as we drink in
our tea it's actually a nano fiber
called nano crystalline cellulose and
these nano crystalline cellulose is so
strong on a weight basis it's about 10
times stronger than steel yep it's made
of sugar so scientists all over the
world believe that nano cellulose is
going to be one of the most important
materials for the entire industry but
here is the problem say you want to buy
a half a tonne of nano cellulose to
build a boat or an airplane well you can
google you can eBay you can even Alibaba
you won't find it of course you're going
to find thousands of scientific papers
and great papers where scientists going
to say that this is a great material a
lots of things we can do with that but
no commercial source so we at the hebrew
university together with our partner
in Sweden decided to focus on
development of an industrial scale
process to produce these nano settlers
and of course we didn't want to cut
trees so we were looking for another
source of raw material and we found one
in fact the sludge of the paper industry
the reason there is a lot of that Europe
alone produce 11 million ton of that
material annually it's the equivalent of
a mountain three kilometres high sitting
on a soccer field and we produce this
mountain every year so for everybody
it's an environmental problem and for us
it's a goldmine so now we are actually
producing on industrial scale in Israel
Nano cellulose and very soon in Sweden
we can do a lot of things with the
material for example we have shown that
by adding on a few percent of Nano
cellulose into cotton fibers the same as
my shirt is made of it increases its
strength dramatically so these can be
used for making amazing things like
super fabrics for industrial and medical
applications but this is not the only
thing for example self-standing
self-supporting structures like shelters
that you can see now actually is now
showcasing in the Venice Biennale for
architecture so nature actually didn't
stop it to one its wonders in the plant
kingdom think about insects cactus for
example have the ability to jump about
100 times its height and that's amazing
it's actually the equivalent of a person
standing in the middle of Liberty Island
in New York and in a single jump go to
the top of the Liberty statue I'm sure
everybody would like to do that so the
question is how caps fries do it it
turns out that they make this wonderful
material which is called
in simple words wrestling which is a
protein is the most elastic rubber on
earth you can actually stretch it you
can squish it and it doesn't lose almost
any energy to the environment now when
you release it snap it brings back all
the energy so I'm sure everybody would
like to have the material but here's the
program to catch cat fleas it's
difficult why because they're jumpy but
now it's actually enough to catch one
and now we can extract its DNA and read
how carefully makes the wrestling and
clone it into a less jumpy organism like
plant so that's exactly what we did so
now we have the ability to produce lots
of resin well my team decided to do
something really cool at university they
decided to combine the strongest
material produced by the plant kingdom
with the most elastic material produced
by the insect Kingdom nano cellulose
with wrestling and the result is amazing
this material in fact it is tough
elastic and transparent so there are
lots of things that can be done with
this material for example next
generation sports shoes so we could jump
higher or run faster and even touch
screens for computers and smartphones
they won't break well the problem is
that we continue to implant synthetic
implants in our body which we glue and
we screw into our body and I'm going to
say that this is not a good idea why
because they fail this synthetic
material fails just like this plastic
fork that is not strong enough for its
performance but sometimes they are too
strong and therefore their mechanical
properties do not really fit their
surrounding tissues but in fact the
reason is much more fundamental the
reason is that in nature there is no one
there
that actually takes my head and screw it
into my neck or take my skin and glue it
onto my body in nature everything is
self assembled so every living cell
whether coming from a plant insect or
human being has a DNA that encodes for
nano bio building blocks many times
there are proteins other times there are
enzymes that make other materials like
polysaccharides fatty acids and the
common feature about all these materials
is that they need no one they recognize
each other and self assemble into
structures scaffolds on which cells are
proliferating to give tissues they
develop into organs and together brings
life so we at Hebrew University about 10
years ago decided to focus on probably
the most important biomaterial for human
which is collagen why collagen because
collagen accounts for about 25% of our
dry weight we have nothing more than
collagen other than water in our body so
I always like to say that anyone who is
in the replacement parts of human being
would like to have collagen admittedly
before we started our project they were
already more than 1,000 medical implants
made of collagen you know simple things
like dermal fillers to reduce wrinkles
augment lips other more sophisticated
medical implants like hard vaults so
where is the problem well the problem is
the source the source of all that
collagen is actually coming from dead
body that the pigs that cows and even
human cadaver so safety is a big issue
but it's not the only one also the
quality now here I have a personal
interest this is my father to be in our
winery in Israel the heart valve very
similar to the one I showed you before
seven years ago was implanted in his
now the scientific literature say that
these hard vaults start to fail 10 years
after the operation no wonder they are
made from old used tissues just like
this wall made of bricks that is falling
apart yeah of course I can take those
bricks and and build a new wall but it's
not going to be the same so in the US
Food and Drug Administration made a
notice already in 2007 asking the
companies to start and look for better
alternatives so that's exactly what we
did we decided to clone all the five
human genes responsible for making type
1 collagen in human into a transgenic
tobacco plant
so now the plant has the ability to make
human collagen brand-new untouched so
this is amazing actually
it's happening now today in Israel we
grow 25,000 square metre of greenhouses
all over the country the farmers receive
small plantlets of tobacco looks exactly
like regular tobacco except that they
have five human genes the responsible
for making type oncology we grow them
for about 50 to 70 days we harvest the
leaves and then the leaves are
transported by cooling tracks to the
factory and there the process of
extracting the collagen starts now if
you ever made a pesto essentially the
same thing you crush the leaves you get
the juice that contains the collagen
concentrate the protein we transfer the
protein to clean rooms for the final
purification and the end result is the
collagen identical to what we have in
our body untouched brand-new and from
which we make different medical implants
bone void fillers for example for severe
bone fractures spinal fusion and more
recently even we've been able to
launched into the market here in Europe
a flowable gel that is used for diabetic
foot ulcer that is now approved for
using the clinic so this is not science
fiction this is happening now we are
using plants to make medical implants
replacement parts for human being in
fact more recently we've been able to
make collagen fibers which are six times
stronger than achilles tendon and that's
amazing now together with our partners
from Ireland we thought about the next
thing adding rezulin to those fibers so
by doing that we've been able to make a
super fiber which is about three hundred
eighty percent tougher and three hundred
percent more elastic so oddly enough in
the future when a patient will be
transplanted with artificial tendon or
ligament made from these fibers we'll
have better performance after the
surgery than we had before the injury so
what's for the future in the future we
believe that we will be able to make
many nano bio building blocks in the
nature provided for us you know collagen
nano cellulose rezulin and many more and
that will enable us to make better
machines they will perform better and
even hard now this heart is not going to
be the same as we can get from a donor
it will be better it actually will
perform better and will last longer my
friends Ian Suleiman once told me a
smart sentence he said if you want a new
idea you should open an old book and I'm
going to say that the book was written
it was written over three billion years
of evolution and the text is the DNA of
life all we have to do is read this text
and embrace nature's give to us and
start our progress from here thank you